The explosive and embarrassing stories about
Donald Trump contained in the new book that
is coming out today, I believe continue to
flow and they are truly the stuff of horrors.
It is now alleged that Donald Trump visibly
struggled to read a passage from the constitution
while he was being filmed for a documentary,
and then flew into a rage during which he
blamed other people in the room and the film
crew for crimp Conkling a pea crinkling, a
piece of paper.
Crumpling I liked that.
Uh, blamed everybody in the room for Trump's
inability to read.
We'd been covering Trump's difficulty reading
for a long time.
Of course, our video Trump fails basic literacy
test now with more than 3.3 million views
on YouTube.
A real classic.
So this is a stunning excerpt from the book
of very stable genius.
We looked at an excerpt yesterday.
The book is by Washington post reporters,
Philip Rucker and Carol Lennon and the excerpt
reads, quote, with led lights on stilts in
front of him.
Trump took a seat.
You're lucky you got the easy part.
Polosi told him cheerfully.
This is Nancy Pelosi's daughter who's the
filmmaker.
It gets complicated after this, but the president
stumbled trying to get out the words in the
arcane, stilted form.
The founding fathers had written.
Trump grew irritated.
It's very hard to do because of the language
here.
Trump told the crew, it's very hard to get
through that whole thing without a stumble.
He added, it's like a different language,
right?
The camera man tried to call him Trump telling
him it was no big deal.
To take a moment and start over.
Trump tried again, but again remarked.
It's like a foreign language.
This is the constitution by the way, which
he claims to so much understand.
He feels as though it's written in a different
language.
They go on to to write in the book quote.
Every time he stumbled, he manufactured something
to blame people and other person in the room
recalled.
He never said, sorry, I'm messing up.
Other people would screw up and say, Oh, I'm
sorry.
They would be self-effacing.
He was making up excuses and saying there
were distracting sounds.
He was definitely blaming everyone for his
inability to get through it.
That was prickly or childish though.
Stiff.
He eventually made it through without any
errors and then again you continuing whatever
the reason for Trump's discomfort with the
reading, several watching agreed this much.
He behaved like a brooding child, short tempered,
brittle and quick to blame mystery distractions
for his mistakes.
I didn't expect this, but I felt sorry for
him.
Another witness said when vice president Pence
is reading it, when former vice president
Dick Cheney is reading it, I knew they knew
the constitution and I thought before he got
this job, he really should have read it.
So this is of course denied constantly by
Trumpists.
They say Trump's reading is fine.
Clearly it's not.
I mean completely unrelated sources of all
kinds that are observing Donald Trump behind
the scenes notice.
Trump really struggles to read.
It's okay.
Just admit it.
Struggling to read doesn't mean you're stupid
or a bad person or that your political ideas
are bad or anything.
It just means he struggles to read.
The question becomes why does he so acutely
struggle to read?
Is he merely dyslexic?
Is the struggling to read part of a broader
cognitive decline?
Did he always struggle to read or did he have
a period where he did not?
Is there some other explanation?
This is not anything to joke about.
If you had a 73 year old in your family that
suddenly had trouble reading, you would want
to figure out what's going on.
You wouldn't pretend nothing's going on.
And yet that is exactly what the most committed
Trumpists insist on doing.
Here is more corroboration from another unrelated
source that Donald Trump, you know, it's like
everybody from people who worked with the
guy on Saturday night live who have nothing
to do with Phillip Rucker and Carol Lennon
of the Washington post.
Everybody says, when you put something in
front of him and he's got to read it, he has
trouble.
He's on video having trouble.
Let's figure out what it is.
That's all.
Doesn't make his political ideas bad.
His political ideas are bad on their own merits.
It just means we should know what is going
on
and if there is some kind of cognitive issue
taking place here.
Let's take a quick break.
Much more coming up on this very busy Tuesday